the Texas teenager accused of planning
an isis-inspired mass shooting is in
jail this morning
prosecutors say that the plot by
seventeen-year-old Mateen Azizi Iran was
foiled during an undercover
investigation by the FBI and local
police he is charged with criminal
solicitation in making a terrorist
threat dean reynolds is up the Collin
County Detention Facility in McKinney
Texas that's north of Dallas Dean good
morning good morning the affidavit
provided by authorities gives us some
stunning details about the alleged
planning by the suspect in this case who
was apparently inspired by an online
guide from Isis and in a manifesto the
police obtained they say the 17 year old
suspect pledged his allegiance to the
terror group did you plan on carrying
out an attack at the Stonebriar center
mall no in an interview with Fox 4 in
McKinney Texas
matina sees the Euron says he does not
deserve the charges against him seem a
bit extreme but according to an arrest
affidavit the suspect allegedly planned
a terror attack for months
officials say he sent over 1,400 dollars
to undercover federal agents to help him
buy assault rifles ammo and tactical
gear his possible targets included a
school and a Hindu temple before he
settled on Stonebriar Center Mall in
Frisco there he conducted surveillance
for weeks in text messages to undercover
agents he details a possible mall attack
writing just run-and-gun
we can take hostages and assess which
ones we can kill CBS News senior
national security contributor Michael
Morell despite its its significant
defeats in Iraq and Syria Isis still is
a threat to radicalizing young men and
young women in the United States Morrell
says the suspect was only caught because
he was sloppy that is the only way to
catch lone Wolf's is them telling others
what they're thinking how they're
feeling what they're planning to do
now the suspect was allegedly planning
to mount his attack during the Muslim
holy month of Ramadan which begins later
this month he is currently being held
here at this facility on three million
dollars bond and if convicted on both
counts this 17 year old could face the
rest of his life in prison
bianna good work on the part of
authorities and thank goodness that he
was not very well-planned Dean thank you